there's got to be some kind of like
responsibility that comes along with
that daunting task of wanting to be the
place for I guess an Asian voice of
course it's a it's a big responsibility
and so is it like Asian voices in
Western countries or what your guys is
like real model here I think that
majority our team is in America
obviously so we do cover a lot of Asian
American news and we cover a lot of news
from like a Western Asians you know
viewpoint in a sense right
and you know the whole premise of next
shark has been just very it's been very
very organic I mean I don't know if you
guys know but it started off as an
entrepreneur site for Millennials I
remember that I like that a lot because
it spoke to me yeah yeah exactly and you
know we did well for a little bit but it
wasn't we didn't do it it wasn't at a
scale where like wow we could really
like you know make a living off of this
or whatever right and we were just
trying to figure out okay well what's
you know what's what's our angle what do
we do right but then we noticed that a
lot of our Asian centric content was
doing well so when we showed like an
Asian entrepreneur or like technology in
Asia we saw like an uptick in you know
traffic and you know just people sharing
or content online and for some reason to
smoke out to them so really okay let's
do a little bit more of that and so all
of a sudden we became kind of like okay
let's let's focus on Asian faces Asian
businesses you know just more slightly
towards Asian and I started doing really
well and then this is 2016 that's when
do the Rio Olympics happen right and
then we started getting all these DMS
you know going hey um you know there's a
lot of Asian athletes of Asian descent
participating in the Olympics and you
guys should cover them because you know
there is in as much visibility for these
athletes and so we were like okay it's
not really in our you know wheelhouse
but we can give it a shot
yeah and then our cover it's like blew
up like crazy I mean even little things
like we covered something like we didn't
even break the story it was a like all
the other mainstream publication already
released it like Vietnam wins their you
know first Olympic gold medal or
something right oh the the guy with the
gun the Sharpshooter I think so yeah
yeah I think so yeah so I mean I
remember just the weekend I'm just like
you know I you know at the time I was
still like doing you
writing to and so I remember just a
weekend I just did a quick ride upon and
enough Sun and it was like you know 500
hits and less than 24 hours I was crazy
you know and so many people were sharing
in and everything and then a couple
months later the we started getting more
DMS going hey like crimes against
asian-americans are some of the lowest
like reported like you guys should cover
more that stuff and so your fan base
actually just created the content for
you yes you gave them what they were
just asking for yeah we just you know
cuz for us I mean I think that it's
important to kind of listen to your
readers and to figure out kind of like
you know what you know what is what is
it that they you know kind of want and
one one to kind of consume and we kind
of base it off of that and so you know I
always give shoutouts to you know a lot
of our readers as Porter's is a reason
why I like you know this is why I'm here
today honestly because all I did was
just listen and you know listen to
feedback I try my best to you know read
you know the PM's and read the emails
like even to this day and so do our
staff so what was that article about
crimes against asian-americans are at
least what does that mean I'm just like
you know for example like oh how do you
say it like let's say the whole dr-dos
situation remember like you know so that
one actually like really really put us
on the map I mean you know when that uh
Vietnamese
I guess Vietnamese American a doctor was
dragged off this forcibly dragged a
flight you know there's like bloodied
and everything and again we weren't the
only we weren't the only publication
report on it I mean tons of publication
reported beforehand but because we built
such a solid Asian following at the time
there was this like analytics company
that was just like trying to rank how
much engagement a Facebook post got
based on a certain subject and so when
they were ranking based on the subject
surrounding this next shark actually
ranked our coverage ranked number three
across Facebook wow it's crazy like we
beat I saw we beat out New York Post and
they're like all these major
publications under us was like wow this
is crazy I mean you know it's so the
stories are right I mean I feel like you
know they it's one of those things where
they don't really get to see this sort
of coverage like anywhere else and so
this is kind of a space where they can
kind of go you know discuss these issues
and to kind of share what's going around
locally mmm Danny I'm sure we share a
fan base because we always use your
guys's articles for JK news appreciate
that bro yeah Matt and
it's because I genuinely care about and
then there they're interesting they're
funny and there's it's not I mean
there's there's so much variety to it
you know you got fashion you got music
you got fun you got and it doesn't get
too political like like that's what I
like about it is I think nowadays you
have to choose a side like you can't be
a news media outlet that does you know
you that does balanced sides yeah
there's gotta be either left or right
yeah and you for us like this is what
we'd say I mean if anybody ever says
asked us us you know wait what are you
politically aligned or whatever and you
know obviously you know as a publication
we have to say yeah we keep tried to
keep us balanced as possible but it's no
secret I mean like our image if you look
at a majority of our staff like a
majority of them aren't definitely more
so like left-leaning
right but you know how we kind of try to
balance it out is like you know we don't
try to shun people that don't really
believe in you know what believe in our
beliefs um but we've had like Trump
supporter Asian Trump supporters write
op-eds on our page and we've gotten
flack for it but at the same time it's
kind of like you know look so many
people voted for you know so many people
voted for Trump you know and you can't
tell me that you know they don't have
like some sort of a voice you know and
so I think that it's important to at
least try to create a dialogue of some
sort you know yeah and we don't know
it's the whole thing is not perfect
right I mean there's still like a long
way to go to figure out where that
equilibrium is and everybody's just
trying to figure out like how to reach
that equilibrium yeah and that's
something I can stand by cuz I think Jay
King news we try to do the same thing
where I mean at the end of the day we're
not genius philosophers we're just there
to [ __ ] around and talk [ __ ] but at the
same time I feel like we'd have a fan
base that is both like liberal and
conservative and some people get they
feel left out if we lean too much on one
side or the other and I think most of us
don't care enough like we'll care like I
like the way I look at politics is like
like WWE and like drama and like
entertainment like to me I don't take it
as serious as other people and I like to
argue so it might sound like I'm just
really about something but I just argue
for the sake of arguing sometimes cuz
it's fun but I have to remember that
people take this [ __ ] serious and this
is something that
like someone's life you know and in and
so I try to do that but I also want the
goal is like the common ground thing and
it's like what where is there a place
where they can agree or maybe even find
a compromise because the way that this
country is going to it's it's it's a lot
of these like people just in their own
bubbles and saying we'll [ __ ] these guys
these guys are they don't know anything
they don't have the right data they're
all [ __ ] brainwashed and the more we
separate like that it just creates chaos
yeah it's it's it's it's hard man I mean
it's uh it's we're worthless we're in
this stage where there's just like no
room for nuance right it's either like
you're either here or either yeah you're
not with us then you know screw you
don't think I think people just they say
they don't like labels but they [ __ ]
love labels dude they like groups they
like being grouped up into a group and
like pointing fingers are saying I'm
better than you that's like that's
generally like what people have that's
that's the same thing with even like
let's say if we were to bring it down
like to Earth YouTube man Hollywood
right there's always this concept of
like I'm better than you
like my I'm a content creator you're
over here sucking Hollywood's dick and
these people are like you don't even
make real movies you know but it's like
why can't people just be happy doing
what they're doing is you know wise good
people like labels they like it they
there's this thing where people are
going on right now they're like oh don't
label me this this and that but you just
say but you [ __ ] love it that's why
you I love it is fun they like they like
the identity and the feeling of
belonging in a certain group yeah I like
to feel like I'm better than people
that's true so I'm like [ __ ] those
Hollywood [ __ ] how many dicks
did you have to suck to be and I move a
lot of dicks but then they get like 20
million doll for their [ __ ] role and
I'm like jealous oh yeah for sure
it's hard man you got to go to the
Oscars sit next to Lil Jon music anymore
Jon dude so I mean like um they're
probably sitting in the back somewhere
you know like with the with the see
lists and be lists it's not in the front
yeah hey did you always want to go into
like journalism no dude you know what
the funny thing is in college you know I
got like I think I tested still had like
a high school reading level like
ass dude like it's looking funny it's
crazy dude it's funny because my parents
have that whole thing where it's like oh
you know Benny's gonna be when I was
born they had this high bar for me where
it's like Oh Benny's gonna be a doctor
someday no I could see it in his face
he's gonna be he's gonna really save
lives and stuff right yeah but I got in
the kindergarten they had stay rely they
had to lower their bar like crazy that's
[ __ ] your old parents as soon as you
got the carrot kindergarten you made
them lose hope that is [ __ ] hilarious
first parent-teacher conference I
remember like you know during spelling
test you're supposed I don't know how it
was for you guys during kindergarten
right but when we took spelling tests
right you know you take a piece of paper
there weren't guests at the time for
some reason there was small desk but you
have to kind of pick a corner and you
know kind of listen to the teacher I was
one of those kids I was just drawing on
my I didn't I didn't pay attention it
was going on I was so oblivious to what
was going on [ __ ] funny so I was just
like I was literally so by the time
everybody handed in their their your
spelling test is like I'd have pictures
all over mine and then so and I remember
like the bar was so low that at the end
of the year like you know how they give
your poor cards they write comments no
bright but yeah Benny's really improved
I mean he stopped talking you know he's
really improved you know he stopped
talking when I talk he doesn't make
weird noises like you know in the corner
he understands that timeout is a you
know it's a punishment now it's not you
know room to just like